ici ça engis ok je serai pas voilà la ca
enregistre hockey au violet pote
j'espère que vous allez bien je vous en
parlais dans la vidéo sur teen d'heure
j'ai aussi reçu un message sur l'ennui
d'ailleurs le gage l'appeler
jean-jacques je vérifier que c'est quand
même pas son vrai prénom
ok donc il s'appelle kevin il serait pas
jean-jacques donc c'est bon on peut
rester sur l'anonymat avec jean-jacques
alors le message que j'ai reçu cette
fois il est un petit peu longs mois je
préfère comme jade c'est le message
un petit peu court et concis et efficace
c'est plus facile pour en faire une
vidéo mais en gros dans une première
partie jean charest qui expliquait que
les coups de fil en fait cela le
déprimait un petit peu parce que ça lui
faisait désordre de remise en question
et cetera mais ça c'était avant
je lis aujourd'hui je vais mieux
vraiment je suis heureux mais l'ennui me
ronge et je suis tombé sur ta vidéo qui
parle du sujet ça faisait longtemps que
je n'avais pas regardé des vidéos et
j'ai tout de suite cliqué quand je les
ai vus je dois avouer que je me suis
vraiment reconnu dans tout ce qui a été
dit mais malgré ça je n'ai toujours pas
de réponse à ça je ne fais rien car je
ne veux rien faire je me sens vide et je
m'ennuie oui comme si je n'avais pas la
force de faire quelque chose pour ne pas
m'ennuyer
je la trouve nulle part je me demande ce
que je n'ai pas compris dans ta vidéo
comment apprivoiser sa pour ceux qui ne
voient pas de quelle vidéo il parle il
parle de celle là je l'émotion
description regardez là si ça vous enfin
je pense à vous plaira peut-être
regarder vous me direz alors jean
jacques déjà merci pour ton message qui
me touche beaucoup
je suis content que ça aille mieux
sachez que beaucoup de gens se sont
reconnus dans cette vidéo ce n'est pas
que jean-jacques le fait de se
reconnaître dedans c'est peut-être
d'ailleurs l'un des commentaires qui est
revenu le plus souvent et même mois en
fait je les fais cette vidéo parce que
c'est quelque chose que je ressentais
aujourd'hui on vit dans une ère où
l'ennui ce n'est plus une denrée rare
ce n'est plus du luxe comme ça a pu
l'être autrefois en fait aujourd'hui
l'ennui est accessible à tout le monde
parce que jean-jacques écrit je pense
que le point important c'est faire
quelque chose pour ne pas s'ennuyer
parce que je suis pas sûr que ce soit la
bonne question l'ennui il va pas
disparaître dans ce qu'on va faire mais
plus dans comment on va le faire
en fait c'est plus une question de
modalités que d'action du coup moi je
veux pas te dire madame fixe fait une
activité sportive bazin max mon [ __ ]
non on va plutôt s'intéresser aux
modalités dans la vidéo je parle
notamment de deux philosophes
kierkegaard et russell qui ont beaucoup
travaillé sur l'ennui et eux ils prônent
un truc qu'on appelle en anglais hyde
omnes et qu'on pourrait traduire par
oisiveté
alors c'est pas oasis jeter dans le sens
de paresse mais c'est oisiveté dans le
sens d'être présent à soi même c'est un
truc était vachement mis en avant par
les philosophes et d'ailleurs russell il
a fait un essai qui s'appelle loges des
loisirs t l'idée c'est de profiter de
cette oisiveté dans un état de pleine
conscience et j'avoue le mot pleine
conscience pour moi elle a longtemps est
enfin le moz les mots du coup mescam à
deux c'est vraiment plein et conscience
donc là de cette idée de pleine
conscience pour moi elle a longtemps été
floues mais en fait c'est assez simple
kierkegaard
il explique qu'il faut pas chercher
l'apaisement via l'extensibilité mais
via l'intensité en rotant petit déj du
matin à ton petit jus d'orange sans le
bien tu vois dans ta bouche qui coule ou
le lait ou ce que tu veux ou leurs
tartines de confiture prend attention
fais attention tu vois je prends note 2
comment la confiture c'est elle sur ce
point le goût qu'elle accorde quand une
marche
par exemple le poids de tes pieds sur le
sol tu fais attention à ça tu sens les
semelles de ses chaussures l'air qui
passe à travers tes doigts
le bruit des petits oiseaux le bruit des
voitures les odeurs aussi les odeurs des
gaz oil les paie des gens qui passent ce
genre de choses et quand tu penses ne
rien faire juste observe sa respiration
sans vouloir la changer ou l'influencé
ou quoi que ce soit pense au poids de
ton corps sur ta chaise ou au poids ton
corps son matelas bref soit pleinement
conscient de tout ce que tu veux et
celui qui est en pleine conscience tout
le temps ne s'ennuie jamais alors
évidemment c'est hyper dur de garder
cette connexion tout le temps moi j'ai
dû rencontrer quelques-uns notamment à
katmandou qui méditaient etc mais et
médite genre plusieurs heures par jour
depuis des années des années
du coup c'est parce qu'on cherche à nous
dans notre mode de vie parce que c'est
trop compliqué mais ce qu'on cherche à
faire c'est peut-être de le faire sur
quelques trajets ou quand on s'ennuie
c'est agréable et le message de jean
jacques me fait aussi penser à vincent
van gogh qui écrivait à son frère que
pour lui il y avait deux types de
paresse dont une qui vient du fait que
il sait pas qui il est ni ce qu'il doit
faire
même s'il sent qu'au fond il est fait
pour quelque chose et pour van gogh
la solution à ça c'est l'amour être un
me être frères et soeurs être amoureux
et cultiver tout ça peut-être parce que
l'amour donne confiance et cette
confiance permet peut-être de révéler ce
pour quoi on pense être fais donc mon
conseil pour toi jean jacques se serait
peut-être de pratiquer davantage la
pleine conscience d'apprendre un petit
peu à se connaître et de cultiver son
cercle social
j'espère que ça ça va t'aider mon cher
sauce voilà voilà j'espère que vous a
plu dans s'ouvre la semaine prochaine
pour une nouvelle vidéo
tiens